here's a question for you yep
um so
you so the bigger names that are
supporters of ethereum it's not small
names no these are Big names big right
uh the big uh hedge funds that are
bullish on uh ethereum these are not
small names these are very very
well-known names right that you're
you're talking about Fortress Arc
Investment Group Brevin Renaissance Tech
there's some of these bigger names
Millions yeah billions so which means
they have access
to uh uh they are banking on them being
it so is this a situation where ethereum
um
doesn't want an xrp and it's a form of
wanting to eliminate competition is that
all it is or it's a form of let's get
rid of these guys and let's not put the
attention on us let's get the attention
to xrp is that kind of what this is sure
I think Joe Lubin said it best I said
when he said that every altcoin
is is spectacularly disadvantaged when
compared to ethereum he said Bitcoin and
ether we've been blessed we have the
regulatory pass we have the free pass
these other folks don't yeah and and
look at how much activity went to
ethereum since that speech in 2018 what
half nfts on ethereum well the article
just came out right I'm looking at this
article ethereum Joe Lube in defense sec
I'm at Ripple lawsuit uh as the SEC is
facing a barrage of criticism for its uh
scatter shot approach to regulatory
cryptocurrencies the much feared
regulatory agency as a supporter within
the industry consensus CEO Joe Lubin and
in a recent interview with the
information Lubin who is known as one
ethereum co-founders claims that the SEC
chair Gary
demands for greater Authority in
regulating cryptos are Justified the
head of ethereum development Studio says
that the agency has a lot of legit
arguments may have legit arguments in
the cases that are being discussed right
now while rippled company that was sued
by a cc in December over its
unregistered security sales accuses the
agency of stiff link innovation in the
U.S Lubin does not think that is the
case I don't believe the SEC is trying
to squelch Innovation and he continues
making other comments about a republican
that xrp was treated on fairly by the
SEC a speech by William Hinman the sec's
former top official in which he said
that ether was not an unregistered
security became a breeding ground for
conspiracy theories about potential
interest within the xrp community some
are convinced that Hinman had skin in
the game merely because of his ties to
Simpson Thatcher Law Firm which is
member of the Enterprise ethereum
Alliance yet the SEC made it clear that
it has not taken an official position on
its regulatory status and Hinman was
only expressing his personal opinion
Ripple seal Brad is careful about his
words Choice steering clear of peddling
free pass conspiracy theories in a
recent interview however he said that
the timing of the lawsuit was suspicious
so now why is uh everybody likes
Dogecoin what is Brad's issue with
Dogecoin you know I don't know other
than I think it comes down to the
utility argument that you brought up
where you said elon's being smart Elon
knows exactly what you said right so
he's going to get you know him and Mark
Cuban who's also into Doge they're
they're selling their merchandise Dallas
Maverick merchandise Tesla merchandise
and they're using smart they're using
those as a means of payment yeah and so
it's going to drive it up and um and
he's right the the reality is Dogecoin
as a means of payment transaction yeah
is better than Bitcoin on the network
there's no doubt about it you know
Bitcoin right now it's digital gold it's
a store of value and that's why you
should buy it that's the use case for
Bitcoin you know ethereum it's the smart
contracts and they're the 2.0 ultimately
and all that's going to happen that's
their story with ripple it is these
Superior payment transactions you can
literally send there's a guy named
Michael Arrington and he moved 50
million dollars
um into his uh uh balance sheet and it
cost him thirty dollars well that that's
the next that was the argument that I
had heard against xrp was the the drug
trafficking argument like okay you can
uh you can buy two million dollars of
cocaine and have it in uh you know
Colombia for 30 bucks in in 10 minutes
and that's you know so it's gonna it's
gonna make the the drug trafficking uh
International drug trafficking and all
smuggling you know that that much easier
and I'm saying like well they're doing
it anyway well it's also it's also
listen the it's all thought about the
criminal stuff because it's a public
Ledger the CIA and the FBI have come out
and said that they basically hope that
terrorism use the distribute Ledger you
can find them it's an open Ledger as
well yeah he said that this is better
for the FBI because now they can catch
the bad guy better I don't know if
that's true or not but that's what he
said Pat they're full of [ __ ] anyway man
because look they got a problem with the
technology that could do this but then
the president's son is selling a
painting for two million dollars like
okay and then we're just supposed to
play beautiful painting this guy's
I mean this guy is incredible like I'd
rather have the laptop shame on you for
discrediting how dare I yeah I mean yeah
it's uh he's a he's a real uh he's a
real crack uh artist with the paintbrush
but I I can't speak for Brad I just
think it comes down to that utility
argument well I read the article to you
on why he said that so here's the
article that just came out on why he has
an issue I think it's on page uh uh five
let me see here uh uh on the bottom okay
here we go bitcoin news uh Dogecoin is
loved by all except Brad uh garlinghouse
Dogecoin is arguably one of the world's
most popular most successful
cryptocurrencies in the world starting
out as a joke roughly eight years ago
and the currency has been established as
one of the most leading digital assets
of today as a marquee cap will run a uh
more than a billion dollars and has
gotten attention from Elon and Mark
Cuban clearly is popular coin and
everyone seems to like it except Brad
Garland gals the CEO Ripple on recent
interview stated that the asset was not
good in the long run when it came to
expansion of the crypto spacing
mentioned I'm actually not convinced
somewhat controversially I guess that
Dogecoin is good for the crypto Market
Dogecoin has some inflationary uh
Dynamics itself that wouldn't make it
reluctant to hold it's interesting that
these words are coming from Brad whose
coin xrp was ultimately outdone by
Dogecoin at one point Doge eventually
Rose so high early this year that it
became world's fourth largest
cryptocurrency by the market and beat
out xrp now uh though now things have
calmed down a bit pushing those to the
side garlic stated that the still fuels
Bitcoin holds the top position in crypto
when it came down to crypto a currency
serving as an inflationary hedge tool he
commented when people are concerned
about holding a fiat currency that might
be inflating and that's devaluing
they're looking at how can I hold other
assets that won't have that same
inflationary Dynamic his main issue with
Dogecoin is that currency does not
employ inflationary barricades the way
Bitcoin does as of now Doja has
approximately 132 billion units
outstanding while an additional 5
million new coins enter circulation
every year so I guess that's the reason
why he has an issue with them in regards
to inflationary barricades well xrp is
you know it has a hundred billion it's
not going to get any more sort of a
similar argument to bitcoin instead of
21 million it's 100 billion and uh but
at the same time you know everyone's in
their tribe in crypto crypto it's just
like a microcosm of everything else in
society everyone's in their tribe you
know when you had kurdon he's a bsv guy
yeah that's it like you asked him well
is there going to be two or three coins
that gonna you know come out of this and
be winners ASP is the one true God you
know that was it whereas I take that
position there's what 7 000 coins most
of them are going to go away but there's
going to be you know a handful that make
it I think xrp is going to make it in
the payment sector I think Bitcoin is
going to continue to be that digital
gold you know store of value and if
ethereum if they end up figuring it out
then I think it could ultimately flip
Bitcoin even it could flip Bitcoin I
think because listen you know a lot of
people say oh you're the xrp attorney
and you're hating on ether I have a
higher investment in ethereum than I do
xrp this this isn't about me this is
about what's right what's right it's
about that reaction that you had as you
were learning this right and the only
difference is I have a law degree and I
said I can do something about it but I
read somewhere the supporters of xrp I
saw Kutcher I saw Madonna Snoop Dogg but
the most random character Bill Clinton
yeah they what is Bill Clinton and xrp
let me tell you something about Ripple
you know we've already went over there
their uh their defense lineup right
their lawyers they had Bill Clinton be
their keynote speaker at their annual
event on their board just this year is a
former U.S um treasury the the her name
Rosie something is Rios is on the
dollars in the 100 bills she was the
treasurer of the United States she's on
their board so they have top-notch
people from the industry uh not just the
crypto industry but the financial
industry are they putting Bill Clinton
on that list because he spoke at an
event are they supporting Bill Clinton
on that list because he owns xrp maybe
they paid him an xrp to speak I don't
know I think it's more about just that
list
former president coming on board yeah
because because it's the right guy to
have on your side because you're dealing
with a lot of liberals on the opposing
side that want to you know regulate the
hell out of you in a phone call from
Bill Clinton and even scarier phone
callers from his wife you kind of have
to take that call and say all right
Hillary we'll we'll leave xrp look at
that sentence that you said man 2021 is
such a trip there's a lot of liberals
that want to regulate you like these
words don't even mean anything anymore
you know who owns xrp Tim Draper I know
he owns xrp and uh The Wolf of Wall
Street Jordan Belfor Jordan Belfor uh
owns xrp and I think uh Jason Derulo and
maybe exhibit maybe exhibit I think I
saw him on Twitter my favorite exhibit
songs of all time yeah yeah back in the
90s yeah but uh it's a shame uh oh
people in the rap game only for the
money and the fame extra large remember
that yeah like that was years ago the
opening was sick so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]